now brainy this is a bit that really is
going to do you're headed which I'm
going to enjoy
I'm going to show you how light can be
polarized by sheets of Polaroid this is
a sheet of Polaroid
it's a polyvinyl alcohol with iodine
thrown in it so in here I'm not sure
which way round it is there are long
molecules which has stretched out and
they conduct along this direction but
they don't conduct that way so that's
what your Polaroid sunglasses made of
stuff like this which is built into it
so it reduces the glare
for example off the road when you're
driving along so I put a sheet of
Polaroid on top of this overhead
projector which produces light and I put
another sheet on top polarized the same
way and they absorb a bit of light for
each direction but if I turn this top
one round so that it is actually
perpendicular to that original direction
you can see that you can kill off most
of the light so there's some turning
backwards and that's gone all the way
around and now I'm going back again and
you can see that it disappears this is
an off cut a bit chopped off from the
bottom of this to make it a square and I
can put it on top of these to let me
square them up and you can't see it at
all I can put it underneath these two
and you still can't see it but if I now
slide it in between you can see I'm
rolling this up in the bottom corner and
sliding it in between you see you can
see it if I turn it around this way it
disappears
if I turn it round to 45 degrees you can
see something quite strong and then turn
it around a bit more and it disappears
it's magic now you see there you don't
know now you see it now you don't
amazing what's going on well I I find
this absolutely fascinating I couldn't
believe this was going to work first but
I'll show you another set of equipment
over here which is some microwaves this
is a microwave generator and it will
generate ways which are polarized in one
particular direction and here is a
receiver which will receive them this
wave has a wavelength which is 3
centimeters now 3 centimeters is about
yay long whereas the light wave is
60,000 times small
so if I set up traveling waves waves
coming out of here and ending up over
here not being reflected then it'll be a
bit simpler so I'll detect this by
turning this on and getting a very nice
big signal now I pick up a sheet of
Polaroid this is my sheet of Polaroid
it's just long conducting wires the same
as it were in those sheets of Polaroid
but you can't couldn't see them there so
now I put it in this way around and you
see that you don't get any signal and I
turn it around and I get a huge signal
on the meter at the back so there it is
nothing get through and I turn it round
slowly and you suddenly see the signal
appear and when it's perpendicular I hit
a really big signal on the screen over
there what's happening here is that this
is sending out waves which are
oscillating with an electric field that
goes up and down in this direction and
as the electric field hits this
conducting wire it induces a current in
here and because of the resistance of
the wire this causes the electromagnetic
wave to be absorbed and heat to occur in
the wire so it gets totally absorbed by
the wire if I turn it around this way
well now the electric field causes a
little bit of current to go across there
but then it hits the other side of the
wire and it doesn't dissipate any energy
just gets stalled there as a capacitance
so this does not absorb nearly as much
energy and so I get quite a large signal
and then I turn it around there and I
get virtually nothing now I want to turn
this around to show you that they're
completely polarized oppositely so if I
have that vertically this is now giving
an electromagnetic wave which is
oscillating vertically this is now
detecting only those waves which are
going horizontally it's just like those
two sheets of Polaroid there so I have a
wave which is coming out and oscillating
this way and this one is not tuned to
detect it at all so I get no signal now
I put the sheet of pyrite in and there's
nothing there if I turn it to 45 degrees
I get a huge signal going through if I
now turn it round to perpendicular I get
nothing so I'll start off vertical
there's nothing there
I turn it round I get a lovely big fat
signal coming about 45 degrees and then
when it goes further round it decays
away to zero so something is happening
if I put this in at 45 degrees
I mean able to get ways which are
oscillating this way to go through here
and be detected by something which is
detecting waves that way I'm changing
this signal which is oscillating this
way to one that's oscillating that way
otherwise nothing would go through have
you done oh well I am done it it's this
sheet of Perot that's done it so if I
imagine this is a wave which is coming
out and has a vertical polarization like
this I can think of that as partly this
angle this side of the set square plus
that one so as I put it in at this angle
if I think of this as being vertically
polarized up and down it's partly this
and partly that so as I put that in
there the bit which is running this way
along this wire is killed off and the
bit which is running that way is now
allowed to continue so I have a state
which is oscillating this way now and
this thing has managed to turn the plane
of polarization of this wave from
vertical to this direction now when at
this wave travels along this way part of
that is horizontal and part of that is
vertical and the horizontal part goes in
so I have a wave I measure it it changes
the state of the system from being
vertically polarized vertically
polarized or one polarized in this
direction once I've done that this state
can be detected by that now that's the
interpretation of this whole experiment
and that's the classical interpretation
in terms of electromagnetic waves now
Brady this is the bit that really is
going to do you're headed which I'm
going to enjoy for the next few minutes
out of this apparatus comes one photon
it is a photon which is oscillating this
way the chances of the photon going
through here a 50/50 can either be going
this way or that way and if I do it 45
degrees they're equal probably
equally probable then you get to this
detector and now it's coming out with
that polarization the chance of going
this way of fifty-fifty so I'm going to
only get a quarter of the signal going
through if this really works and that's
the explanation why the signals gone
down but notice now as this photon comes
through I had to talk about
probabilities of what goes on
it is not deterministic and if you go
through the mathematics you'll find that
these states which I would like to
represent using a ket which is a
triangle like this and you put the
symbol in as a triangle that ket state
changes from one to the other and I in
here in between I have a mixture of two
different states and it's a mixture of
these two states that allows me to
interpret this experiment so it's much
harder for poor old brains you
understand because somehow quantum
mechanics is biting him on the backside
here and he really doesn't like me to
talk about mathematics at all but
without that and without the idea of
splitting this into two different states
added together I have no explanation for
what's going on so get your head around
that Brady I'll just edit that bit out
have some glasses working sunglasses
work well I haven't got them but I used
to have clip-on / IDEs and somehow if
you're looking at light which is
reflected off the road for example the
light that's polarized in this direction
is taken away so you find that you have
transverse polarization only and if you
get rid of that you then reduce the
glare off the roads completely and so
you don't get a nasty reflection off the
roads or if you have a river and you're
looking at the surface of a still river
or pond it will get rid of the glare off
the pond and you can actually see into
the pond and see all the fishes below
the other reason they work is because it
seems to attract all the girls if you're
really cool unlike me